man muss nicht jede wendung im bregtal
für einen ausweis jahrhundertealter
starts klugheit in london halten
um dennoch hohen respekt vor dem ringen
einer nation um eine grundfrage zu
empfinden
england war immer zugleich drinnen und
draußen kalt europa halb indien zugleich
europäische macht und weltmacht
wie hat es schon einmal so unnachahmlich
literarisch gegenüber die google
ausgedrückt wenn ich mich zwischen ihnen
und amerika zwischen ihnen und dem
offenen meer entscheiden muss entscheide
ich mich immer für das offene meer
und es wäre wirklich eine ironische
volte sollte eine parlaments regel die
auf das jahr 1604 zurückgeht eine dritte
diesmal vielleicht erfolgreicher
abstimmung über den viel verhindern
darf ich daran erinnern dieses haus das
die entscheidung zum brett auf
demokratischem wege gefallen ist
[Applaus]
die mehrheit der briten hat beschlossen
die eu zu verlassen
ja es war eine knappe mehrheit doch
diese konstellation ist heute normal und
historisch bedeutende entscheidungen
sind oft durch knappe mehrheiten
herbeigeführt worden
es war eine demokratische entscheidung
also etwas das in der eu eher selten
vorkommt und was wir derzeit erleben ist
der versuch das unerwünschte ergebnis
einer demokratischen entscheidung
vielleicht doch noch rückgängig zu
machen meine damen und herren spott ist
kaum angebracht wenn einer unserer
ältesten und wertvollsten verbündeten
sich in politischen krämpfen bindet es
sind eben nicht die fehlinformation der
praxis befürworter die zu dieser
situation geführt haben
das sind die zwei seelen in der brust
des engländers die dieses dilemma
herbeigeführt haben
und deshalb wäre es auch die aufgabe der
bundesregierung nicht beiseite zu stehen
und dem schicksalhaften drama seinen
lauf zu lassen sondern beherzt
einzugreifen frau bundeskanzlerin das
paket wieder aufzuschnüren
oder zumindest mit zusätzlichen
erklärungen zu versehen
es kann doch nicht so schwer sein den
briten den einseitigen ausstieg aus dem
back stopped zu ermöglichen und es fällt
den 27 bei gott kein zacken aus der
krone für eine kurze übergangszeit die
niederlassungsfreiheit auszusetzen
rosinenpickerei ist dafür das falsche
wort angesichts eines dramas das die
zukunft unseres kontinents bestimmt und
darüber entscheiden wird ob
großbritannien das uns jahrelang in
berlin verteidigt hat uns auch künftig
freundschaftlich verbunden bleibt
denn verletzungen meine damen und herren
an den seelen der völker sind schwer zu
heilen als materielle schäden
gerade wir deutschen können davon ein
lied singen
regelbasierte multilateral i tät kam bei
ihnen auch wieder vorfall bundeskanzlers
ein wohlklingendes abstraktum das
niemanden zu seelischen anstrengungen
verführt und von herrn barnier
repräsentiert eher abschreckt und
spaltet als zusammenführen ein appell
der bundeskanzlerin an die verhandelnden
einen kleinen schritt aufeinander
zugehen könnte da vielleicht wunder
wirken
allerdings müsste man dafür von dem
gedanken abstand nehmen deren brüssel
immer mitgedacht wird die briten dafür
zu bestrafen dass sie einen weg gehen
wollen
die in manchen hauptstädten des
kontinents für politisch inkorrekt
gehalten wird und der niemals auf eine
weise ins freie führen darf die
nachahmer anspruch könnte doch gerade
darin müsste sich die stärke der
europäischen union erweisen dass sie
niemanden gegen seinen willen festhält
es ist unsinn und ein zeichen von
fehlendem vertrauen in die eigene
attraktivität wenn man bei einer
trennung sich so aufführt wie die um und
momentan gegenüber den dritten die
europäische union zu ihrer eifrigen
befürworter sein zwangs verband sondern
eine freiwillige übereinkunft die jedes
volk jeder staat jederzeit auflösen
können wenn sie es für nötig halten
es ist an der zeit dass die europäischen
regierungen das beweisen und
großbritannien eine ebenso fähre wie
kluge chance geben vermerkt ich
appelliere an sie machen sie damit den
anfang
dann wird nämlich den eindruck nicht los
dass es der eu um anderes als um den
frieden der lanz geht nämlich zu
verhindern dass großbritannien zu einem
deregulierten von niedrigen löhnen und
niedrigen steuern geprägten wettbewerber
die eu wird ihr quid pro quo wenn
großbritannien weiter den vollen zugang
zum eu markt will muss es sich weiter an
die eu-standards zur besteuerung
beschäftigung zu wettbewerb und umwelt
halten also praktisch ein mitglied ohne
mitsprachrecht zarte gemüter werden dass
abmessungen wenn die die zeitungen
aufschlagen lesen wir immer von dem
wirtschaftlichen schaden der den briten
durch den praxis entstehen werde wir
lesen aber nichts über den schaden für
die eu denn auch wir verlieren meine
damen und herren deutschland zuvörderst
geben wir den briten etwas mehr zeit
aber nicht das gefühl aus einem
gefängnis ausbrechen zu müssen
dazu müsste man freilich von all den
effekten die zu einer schmutzigen
scheidung führen zur vernunft
zurückkehren
und ich kann nur noch mal wiederholen
formate machen sie damit den anfang denn
das ist politik im deutschen interesse
ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]